on Wednesday we saw what has to be one
of the most stunning political contrasts
of all time as I was watching I put out
this tweet
president Trump signing a historic trade
deal 1 Nancy Pelosi was yucking it up
with her pathetic impeachment pens in my
usual measured way I called her a
divisive spiteful hate-filled charlatan
and in case you think that was over the
top look at what she actually said but
he has been impeached
he's been impeached forever they can
never erase that impeached forever
there's the contrast Pelosi stunts
versus Trump results Americans can see
what's going on look what happened when
the president and first lady entered the
stadium at the CFP National Championship
game last week
that is the sound of Americans who are
proud of their president because of what
he's doing for their country proud of
the Soleimani strike the first time
Iran's murderous regime has been
seriously confronted by America for 40
years proud of the China terrorists -
the first time any Western leader has
stood up to them this week they signed a
phase one trade deal over 30 billion
dollars in US Agriculture exports more
than 50 billion for energy over 70
billion for manufacturing even more
important finally protection for our
companies intellectual property and a
pledge from China to stop the
competitive devaluations that previously
gave them an unfair trade advantage next
week the president will sign the u.s.
MCA just passed by the Senate which
affects 40% of our trade our farmers
will now be able to sell more dairy
products to Canada American patents and
trademarks will be better protected and
above all the u.s. MC is fantastic news
for our auto workers with new rules to
prevent them from being undercut by
cheap foreign labor it is the most Pro
worker trade deal in history a massive
boost for our economy which will create
hundreds of thousands of new jobs then
on infrastructure a huge move the other
week that barely got covered the Trump
administration sweeping away the
bureaucracy that's led to nonsense like
a 12-mile expansion of Interstate 70 in
Denver taking 13 years to build these
reforms will speed up the construction
of new roads everywhere a vital move for
working Americans because infrastructure
boost productivity and more productive
workers get paid more it comes on top of
steps the administration has already
taken to help build pipelines across the
country that's helped us become a net
oil exporter which in turn gives us a
freer hand in the Middle East yes
there's a strategy here people and it's
working you see the same on immigration
the number of border apprehensions fell
in December for the seventh straight
month thanks to a coherent set of
actions including the new wait in Mexico
policy for asylum seekers and remember
the president's threat of tariffs on
Mexico the establishment freaked out you
can't do that they said that's not how
it worked using trade policy for an
immigration objective
well it may have been unconventional but
it did work
Mexico sent troops to their border and
the numbers of low-wage immigrants
plummeted that's helped boost jobs and
earnings for the lowest-paid American
workers reversing decades of stagnation
another sign of a joined up policy
strategy that's working and all that
before the recent court victory on the
border wall in his re-election ad
President Reagan famously said it's
morning in America well in this
re-election year we can say for sure
that the Sun is out and shining bright
record high stock market lowest
unemployment in 50 years lowest in
history for women African Americans
Hispanic Americans but those are just
the well-known results look deeper
there's been more wage growth in almost
every age group as Americans benefit
from a pro-growth Pro and to prized
policy agenda politicians go on and on
about the middle class but look at the
actual results between 2016 and 2018 the
number of taxpayers making between
$100,000 and 200,000
eight percent while those making less
than 25,000 fell by five percent why is
this happening in part because of the
Trump policy strategy different to
anything we've seen before he's taking
traditional conservative ideas and
combining them with new populist ones
appointing conservative judges and
criminal justice reform tax cuts and
paid family leave probe business on
regulations and pro worker on trade and
immigration building up our military and
standing up to China but there's a
personal aspect to this too which I
recognize from my experience unlike
other TV hosts I've run companies and
worked in government and so I know how
hard it is to make change happen last
week I said Trump was different because
he's not ideological he's pragmatic he's
a problem-solving businessman you saw
that on display at the signing of that
China trade deal now this may seem like
a small example but it illustrates a big
point the president mentioned how there
hadn't been July the 4th fireworks at
Mount Rushmore
decades I said you mean you can't have
fireworks because of the environment
yeah environmental reasons I said what
can burn its stone you know it's stone
it's great so nobody knew why they just
said environmental reasons so I called
up our people and within about 15
minutes we got it approved and you're
gonna have your first big fireworks
display at Mount Rushmore and I'll try
and get out there if I can you see most
politicians would just accept the
establishment line sorry you cannot do
that it's a totally different mindset
when you put an outsider in the Oval
Office that mindset is what's delivering
results on deregulation immigration and
the border trade and all the rest of it
here's another key point this president
loves business I've never seen any
politician call out such a long list of
companies to praise like the president
did last week here's just a brief
example David Dabney of ups ups is doing
very well
Darius Adam check of Honeywell great
company al Kelly visa al Kelly al Kelly
Thank You Nancy
Fowler Taco afford Sanjay Murata of
micron credible company Jim Morrison of
Jeep what a great brand jeepers what a
job they've done that is a great brand
that attitude is how the president and
Ivanka Trump have helped create 14
million new training places by working
with the private sector instead of doing
it through government bureaucracy
critics say the president just wants yes
people around him but look at how he
built his China team starting with his
ambassador former Iowa Governor Terry
Branstad Tim I was going in to make a
speech before the election and he said
sir please don't say anything bad about
China it's the first time anyone ever
said that to me
and I said who is this guy he's the
governor of Iowa he just said don't say
bad about China so I had to rip up about
half of my speech right and I said why I
said well we do a lot of business hey
man I think I can go on the opposite
side of the spectrum perhaps from the
governor his attitudes a little
different our trade adviser Peter
Navarro right Peter he's a little
different we have all types all this is
why he's delivering in my impeachment
he's not just a joke but an insult to
every American who has a right to expect
that Congress like the president is
spending its time getting real results
for workers and families of course you
can forget about that from today's
decadent Democrats but the best thing
the president can do is to focus on
policy on results so we continue to see
that contrast between Trump results and
Democrats dance if you only get regular
updates on policy results we're
revamping our social media to do just
that so please follow us now at Steve
Hilton X and at next Rev FNC all right
let's bring it in our guest further
Knight founder of Turning Point USA
Charlie Kirk author of the upcoming book
Maggard doctrine the only ideas that
will win the future is that pro-trump
book chart just like just Jenna Ellis is
here she's part of the president's legal
team on impeachment and former deputy
national security adviser and author of
the new book revolution Trump Washington
and We the People katie mcfarland by the
way where's your book Jenna I was going
to say yes I have a book it's called the
legal basis for a yes you can get that
on Amazon Barnes and Nobles my book I
want to ask Charlie to comment on
something that really shocked me today I
shouldn't be shocked but I was okay so
I've just set out there you got a
contrast between the real results in the
real world and what the impeachment fast
is all about I think any reasonable
person would at least acknowledge that
that contrast this morning on NBC's
flagship show Meet the Press with Chuck
Todd they have a whole hour literally
not one minute not one minute on
anything in the real world nothing about
this historic trade deal about what's
going on
sweet USMC and the stuff that actually
effects their viewers I just thought
it's completely outrageous it is so the
Americas divided but it's not divided
the way that the media wants us to
believe it's divided between the ruling
class that is just so infatuated with
impeachment and destabilizing this
destabilizing this president and
revitalization that's happening in this
country I mean Steve your opening was
brilliant for a variety of ways but you
talked about you can come back thank you
but more than anything else you showed
that the president comes at it from a
common sense perspective pragmatism and
it's not necessarily ideological at time
so it's tax cut tax cuts with paid
family leave
standing up to China with rebuilding our
military strong and immigration but also
pro free enterprise and look at the
results so the ruling class the wise men
of Washington the kingdom of Washington
DC their entire agenda last 40 years had
now been proven completely incorrect
they've been getting rich while America
really has been falling behind
yeah and it's a disgrace that the media
continues to ignore the results of this
president because they just can't stand
him personally but that's the thing
that's why I wanted to set out the
results because you know I back in 2016
I kind of thought well Donald Trump the
candidate was likely to be better than
Hillary Clinton on the key issue of
who's going to help those who've been
left behind by globalization and it's
something like this as time has gone on
I've got more supportive because of the
results you just look at them and
usually think he's really delivered
exactly what was supposed to happen and
those are facts but general I want to
get your legal brain on this and switch
through directly to the impeachment
story well it is just a story well they
want so to that point I would like your
legal opinion can somebody sue Pelosi
for damages for the total time-wasting
boss of this impeachment well you know
she herself should be impeached because
this is just this is just ridiculous
technically comp well I mean she should
be removed you know and so yes she can
and in the polls and that's exactly what
this is about because the the 90-second
version of what's going on in this
impeachment we saw that the house
managers filed their 111 page brief
essentially what they are arguing is
that no person is above the law we are
pro Constitution we are Pro rule of law
and the answer to that what the
president
arguing is of course that's true that no
one's above love but state a law that's
actually been broken here what is a
crime so there is nothing that they have
alleged that is actually on the books as
a law that he's broken so let's actually
look at the Constitution Article 2
section 1 says that all executive power
is vested in a president of the United
States and so what that means is that
foreign policy decisions and all of the
executive authority is vested in the
president this is a policy dispute what
the Democrats are trying to do is to
wield a majority opposition party power
in the house and require a sitting
president of the United States to answer
for his constitutionally vested policy
decision in the context of a Senate
impeachment trial that is absolutely
unconstitutional and it's violating the
rule of law and that's why this
precedent and what Jay Sekulow and Pat
Cipollone argued yesterday is absolutely
correct that this has to be dismissed
out of hand because there is not abuse
of power obstruction of Congress are not
laws on the books that he's violated
that's awfully complicated and I've been
through an MP she's complicated look I
think the Democrats have already lost
they just don't realize it yet because
there's their three possible outcomes
here right one there's a trial in the
Senate it's long extended there are a
lot of interview people I'm coming up
and testify do you really think they're
gonna beat Donald Trump in the greatest
reality TV show of all time this is a
guy who created reality television and
what's impeachment a reality television
show the media is going to get rich on
it politicians are gonna get rich on at
Donald Trump's going to beat him or
they're going to quickly do away with
this and then look like they were
wasting time so they're either gonna
look incompetent or mean and petty
just a quick Katie just why here we
could have lots more impeachment later
on but just to close out this bit by the
with your experience by this time by the
way from a couple of weeks ago we were
being told we're going to be in the
middle of World War three yeah over Iran
I mean what do you make of how that's
turned out well I think President Trump
had a very good policy right from the
beginning fix the American economy
rebuild the American military and then
put sanctions on Iran withdrawal from
the Iran nuclear deal and squeeze them
to the point where they have no options
they don't have a military option again
they don't have an economic option
against us and then force them to come
to the negotiating table on our terms
and if they don't the Iranian people
will change that's who you see the
results I mean literally this week
finally the Europeans coming round what
I have to well they happen this week
very interesting crop knew that they
were going to and so now everybody's
aligned against Iran including the
Iranian people who are out on the
streets protesting the regime